today we are starting with something on
the top of everyone's mind right now
we've all read about the tragic mass
shooting in atlanta this week
eight innocent people were killed six of
them
asian women we grieve for the victims
and their loved ones and this act must
be seen
in the context of a disturbing increase
in racist attacks
against asians we condem anti-asian hate
and stand
with our asian american and pacific
islander
communities today a
dear friend of ours has graciously
agreed to talk to us
about this actress ashley park shared a
powerful
personal video on instagram and touched
so many people already nearly two
million people
and counting fast have watched this
please take a look
with the acts of violence against the
asian elderly with
all of these close to 4 000
hate crimes that happened in the past
year
i i'm always wondering
why like how did it come to this like
why
why is there that hate and these things
happen when people
have rage and entitlement
and when they prey on the weak and i
really don't want
i really i really don't want to cry
right now because i do not want to
perpetuate the idea that asian women are
weak
because we're not we're not
please welcome our dear friend ashley
park
i'm drew oh ashley i'm
so happy to talk to you i am
really happy to talk to you too you were
the voice that i wanted us all to have
the benefit
of hearing from and your video was
so personal and vulnerable and you
actually
said in it that you hesitated about
sharing it are you glad that you did
i am glad that i did i definitely
i think you see at the end of the video
too um
i say that it was just for me i think it
was the set of circumstances i almost
gaslet myself into not sharing it
um and i realized that i had been
kind of gaslighting myself my whole life
into not sharing those things
so i i decided to record something
because i was going through all of these
articles as we all have and all of these
different reposts
and stories and trying to make sense of
stuff and i thought it might be helpful
and make
somebody else feel not as isolated as i
was feeling and i didn't want people to
be grieving on their own as we all have
been
this past year so i'm so glad you posted
it
because i'm so glad that i get to be a
part of a show
that can pivot overnight and say i want
the privilege of speaking to my friend
ashley
and yet everyone on this planet
thanks to social media has a powerful
platform as well and when i see what you
did with yours
it is not often that something garners
millions of views overnight
what you did connected with people and
was utterly powerful
thanks true thank you and one i
i you know i said this to your team but
i
i first of all didn't expect for it to
go
viral in a sense at all and when you
reached out um out of everybody who kind
of reached out and wanted to
talk about the video talk about what i
said um i felt most comfortable coming
to you because it was
when i made that video it was to my
friends it was to my
the people in my life it was too um
really i mean to everyone but i felt so
comfortable being able to speak about it
because it is so personal still like
um and it's something that's still a
part of my identity and it's something
that i'm
reflecting on for the first time in my
life so
um thank you for being a safe space in
that way
i'm so glad what is your advice to
people
on what they can do right now
first of all and i talked about this in
the video i think that the thing that
everyone can do is think about what
they're saying
you know it starts with the president
who calls something the kung fu virus
something that is impacting the entire
world and it makes an enemy
of a certain group of people and to be
honest
when he said that even i
you know everyone in my life that i know
nobody was everyone kind of um
shook it off kind of thought oh that's
just something he's saying it's not a
very serious thing there's no
repercussions from that how crazy
um it's not dangerous and
i think that the things that we say you
know i i just
i just remember very recently that when
i was really little
i remember and i didn't even realize it
was trauma at the time but i remember
somebody's telling me
oh you're not american you're asian
american
and at the time i thought huh okay great
well i want to belong
all i've ever wanted to do is belong
that's all we all want to do right
um and the only way to belong was in
erasing the asian
so especially now i think another
circumstance that kind of led to that
video was the fact that i had just left
new york where
this year is the first time in my life
especially in a white hollywood where
i've embraced being asian and i'm so
excited
by that part of myself and i was living
in new york where
every time i was going outside for the
past month i was putting on not only a
cat my mask my sunglasses
my headphones and not listening to music
so i could be aware of myself i was
fearful
and i was hiding the fact that i was
asian because i didn't know who was
going to jump out at me and i think that
the grief that happened with this
atlanta shooting
was knowing that it was malicious was
knowing that
someone had thought about it and wanted
to target people who looked like me
um and that's when i was that's when i'm
a big scaredy cat i'm scared of
everything but i'm not a fearful person
and i am right now um and that's how
so in moving forward we need allies to
be there with us like on the ground
level when someone says something i
i should be able to stand up for myself
but i am so conditioned
in growing up in this world and in this
industry where i cannot speak up for
myself
because the only person who leaves that
situation harmed is me
the only person so and it's my job to
try to infiltrate
and try to be a lovely person to work
with
and a good human because that's what we
all want to be but
we have to be able to stand up for each
other we have to be able to stand up for
um our black brothers and sisters our
brown brothers and sisters for the aapi
community for
um gay people for everybody you know and
um
it's the active ally ship that's gonna
move us forward i'm so
in awe of what you just said because i
was speaking with my best friend one of
my very best friends of 20-something
years robin
and she is of indonesian descent and
dutch and her father is indonesian
and she was crying this morning worried
for her elderly father in the wake of
what's happening
and i was holding her and she through
tears said
they just got vaccinated and the minute
they were able to go out of their house
it's no longer for him safe to go out of
his house
and i was so struck by that you spoke
about the next generation
in your post and as we worry for our
elders and we worry
about our friends alongside of us right
now
what is your hope for the next
generation as we do have to attack
all of these issues all of them yeah
well i think it starts at an educational
level it starts with our kids it starts
with
what i had said what i kept on thinking
with all of this violence and everything
is at the end of the day i think about
the kid that these these murderers
and these violent people were and who
at what point could have
taught them to be good um and it starts
with it really starts with us and i'm
really appreciative of people
who are as positive and as good as you
who use their platform in that way
because
it really does start with us and we can
i think we can do it i really do
well your voice is the platform and i'm
honored to be a part
of what you're doing which is embracing
that voice and putting it out there
and making change you are the person
we're going to be looking to and
learning from no pressure
but i'm so glad that you put yourself
out there because it is galvanizing the
evidence is
real everyone is watching your video we
are listening to you
and as we all search for next steps one
thing please go to our website where
we'll be sharing our resources and
support for our asian american
viewers and asian island pacific
islanders for those
outside of the asian community we're
going to have resources for how you can
learn
and take action and i thank you ashley
so much
may we talk about the deep and the
meaningful
and embracing entertainment and optimism
and joy and
everything in between together yay
thank you
[Music]